So instead, we're going to look at another algorithm, one which is far better in terms of work complexity.
This implementation was written by Duane Merrill and his colleagues and published in 2012.
What's inefficient about the previous algorithm
is that we visit the same edge over and over again on each iteration, but we only set its depth once.
If we could, instead, only visit an edge when it's ready to be processed and never visit it again,
we'd be much more efficient.
So let's go back to the serial algorithm and think about why it's an efficient algorithm.
It's efficient because it tries to minimize the number of visits to nodes,
and it does so by maintaining a frontier
that marks the boundary between visited nodes and unvisited nodes.
At any given time, only the nodes that border the frontier are subject to computation.
This is different than our brute force N squared algorithm,
where every node is touched on every iteration.
How do we implement something like the frontier on the GPU?